Millie's wonderful Jake is very very
happy John Bon Jovi giving his stamp of
approval on son Jake's engagement to
Millie Bobby Brown it's fine by me
The Rocker chairs shares thoughts on the
latest episode of siriusxm's radio AMD
Congratulations by the way on the big
engagement news the latest one yeah
three of my four three of your four
engaged for Bon Jovi he's happy to be
welcoming a famous daughter-in-law into
his family even if at such a young age
do you worry as a dad about about how
old or how young law of age matters you
know if you find the right partner and
and you grow together I think that would
be my advice really is growing together
is is wise I think that all of my kids
have found the people that they think
they can grow together with and and we
like them all I love you too
and Bon Jovi is familiar with Millie's
work on her hit show stranger things
I've seen it of course Millie's
wonderful
Jake popped the question last month with
Millie sharing the big news on Instagram
it's very exciting I'm so happy she
captioned the pig with a lyric from
Taylor Swift's song Lover
love her I've loved you three Summers
now honey I want them all that's how we
do it while the couple rarely shares
much about their romance last year
Millie gushed over Jake who came as her
date to the Enola homes 2 premiere and
you have made it a Family Fare and a
little bit of a day
I know he's pretty um
there's no official wedding date set for
the two yet but until then looks like
they're enjoying engaged life as they
prepare for the big day oh 100
[Music]
thank you